merci annie monsieur le président cher
laurent wauquiez chaire joseph daul
l'homme solide de l'europe
shirani merci pour ce beau discours
rassembleur chers amis et vous me
permettrez de pas pour citer une
nouvelle fois mais cette salle est
pleine
voilà je rassure ceux qui voudraient
partir un peu en avance les écrans
pourront servir tout à l'heure pour le
coupe du monde de football enfin je dis
ça je dis rien comme disent les jeunes
unis dans la diversité
c'est la devise de l'europe et qui a
raison a ni de souligner la belle figure
européenne et de notre mouvement qui
était simone veil parce qu'elle avait
graver sur son épée d'académicien d'un
côté la devise de la république liberté
égalité fraternité et de l'autre côté
unie dans la diversité
mon cher laurent aujourd'hui qui a
réussi à faire en sorte que nous avons
montré l'union dans la diversité au
niveau des républicains oui nous le
savons nous sommes issus de familles
politiques différentes
les gaullistes et centristes les
libéraux les radicaux les humanistes l
ai trouvé d'autres mots trouver d'autres
non j'ai même trouvé quelques fois
quelques différences à l'intérieur même
de ces formations politiques et ce qui
est important c'est que nous soyons
capables non pas d'aboutir à des
querelles de personnes mais à un projet
d'idées vous voulez supprimer les
querelles de personnes il n'y a qu'une
méthode accepter la diversité et le
débat d'idées
rien n'altérera chez laurent et moi et
toute l'équipe
la volonté de rassembler mais le
rassemblement c'est la richesse de la
diversité au service de l'union voulait
reconstruire notre famille politique
voulait redonner des couleurs à notre
projet il n'y a qu'une méthode porter
ensemble un projet pour la france et un
projet pour l'europe et il n'y a pas
franchement de débats plus passionnant
que le débat européen
passionnant passionné quelquefois
caricaturer mer un débat tier 2 brûlante
actualité
qu'est ce qu'il nous faut certains
disent pourquoi vous voulez changer le
break site
la bascule d'un certain nombre de pays
vers des gouvernements populistes et
anti européens l'italie à nos portes
gouvernée par deux coalitions
antinomiques
qu'est-ce que vous voulez que nous ne
changeons rien qu'on continue à aller
vers le fédéralisme bea
et bien non monsieur macron nour même
l'europe et on veut la changer
[Applaudissements]
le rassemblement c'est d'abord une très
belle tribune qui a été signé par
laurent wauquiez mais aussi gérard
larcher christian jacob bruno retailleau
franck proust une tribune qui disait
voilà où sont nos valeurs
et voilà où nous voulons aller une
deuxième tribune a suivi à la demande de
laurent qui partait d du conseil de
sensibilité qu'il a voulu mettre en
place pour faire vivre la diversité et
36 personnalités sont venues les signer
avec l'ensemble des députés européens
voilà le rassemblement lors ce matin
brice disait dans la voiture j'ai
entendu une radio qui disait il vont se
déchirer
caramba encore manquer on ne s'est pas
déchiré
on a accueilli tout le monde on a
accueilli fraternellement tout le monde
et on leur a dit si vous voulez
travailler avec nous pour un projet
venez vous êtes les bienvenus si vous
voulez contester ou dire des petites
phrases rester dehors
ils sont rentrés et ils ont participé au
projet oui cette europe
nous l'aimons ça nous enlève pas la
lucidité nous voyons bien ce qui va pas
et ce matin les députés européens ont
bien montré leur enthousiasme et aussi
leurs critiques
et bien moi je veux dire aujourd'hui à
laurent wauquiez qui les noms du
président je veux dire que ça peut
étonner les uns et des autres qu'ils
disent
après ce qu'il disait avant son élection
ça peut étonner
peut-être même un petit landerneau dans
lequel on se dit et quand est-ce qui va
recentrer le discours change rien
laurent ton discours que tu as tenu
c'est la fidélité aux teintes et
engagement nous allons faire vivre la
diversité comme tu l'a voulu mais nous
allons conserver notre unité
parce que c'est la crédibilité que nous
devons à l'ensemble de nos militants
[Applaudissements]
aujourd'hui mes amis grâce à vous nous
avons franchi une étape décisive parce
que nous avons porté poser les bases de
notre projet nous avons construit le
socle dès demain dans toute la france à
partir des sept propositions qui ont été
validés à l'unanimité en bureau
politique
à partir de ces cette proposition vous
avez un outil vous avez une charpente
sur lequel on peut continuer à
construire le projet européen oui on
n'est pas rentré dans les détails mais
justement aujourd'hui vous avez la plus
belle démonstration d'un parti politique
ouvert d'un parti politique qui
s'offrent au débat national et qui va le
faire sur des propositions concrètes
demain le projet européen va se
construire sur cette charpente et demain
le projet européen des républicains il
montrera bien qu'il n'a pas besoin de
dire qu'il est contre le nationalisme
étroit de madame le pen ou contre le
fédéralisme bea de monsieur macron ça
sera notre projet ça sera votre projet à
sera le projet des citoyens français qui
se seront appropriés l'envi de changer
l'europe
il a envie de continuer à l'aimer je
voudrais chers amis vous faire partager
une conviction qui la vôtre si j'en suis
sûr je suis européen parce que je suis
français victor hugo disait l'europe ne
peut être tranquille tant que la france
n'est pas contente
il avait raison et la france est pas
contente
comment être content
quand on constate que le rêve européen
des père fondateur s'évanouit
alors que l'europe devrait porter des
grands projets elle produit des normes
qui nous limite alors qu'elles devraient
protéger
elle expose alors qu'elle devrait être
ouverte sur le marché elle est offerte à
la concurrence déloyale alors qu'elle
devrait rassembler les peuples elle
apparaît indifférente à leurs
préoccupations quotidiennes à leurs
craintes et à leurs espérances
et pourtant parce que je suis français
je ne peux pas ignorer ce qu'elle a
apporté l apporter la paix elle a
participé abattre les murs elle a
participé à lutter et à battre les
totalitarismes
elle a ouvert les portes de l'espérance
et de la démocratie
elle a apporté à la france la stabilité
financière elle a favorisé la croissance
aujourd'hui la déception est encore plus
grande
cet espoir s'est transformé en
contestation la contestation s'est
transformée en colère et nous voyons
bien que cette colère des peuples qui à
nos portes
chez nos amis italiens pourtant
signataire du traité de rome à l'origine
de l'union européenne sont en train de
dar rejeté et bien l'europe
soyons sommes bien conscients doit se
réformer se réinventer ou bien elle va
disparaître et parce que je sais
français parce que je suis français je
sais le prix des frontières je sais très
bien que d'en haut de la délégation
française
mon cher joseph à strasbourg on voit
bien dans la forêt continue qui sépare
la france de l'allemagne
combien de sang et de larmes ont été
versées pour créer une frontière
on va vous dire des frontières ça c'est
par non les frontières c'est la paix les
frontières c'est la paix parce que ça
permet de dire à l'autre que je respecte
ce qu'il est
ça m'oblige à dire ce que je suis je
suis français
fierté là je la tiens du fond des âges
et parce que je suis français je
respecte le peuple qui est de l'autre
côté de la frontière une frontière
on peut la franchir pour se défendre on
peut la franchir au cir aussi pour
soutenir et se courir le persécuter mais
refusé de l'abolir
c'est protéger les plus faibles c'est
protéger les siens vous le savez tous
l'absence de frontières c'est une très
belle opportunité pour les riches les
puissants et les barbares et les
terroristes et frontière est le protège
les plus modestes
l'effort et les terroristes vont où ils
veulent les faibles et des citoyens
restent où ils peuvent
parce que je suis français je veux une
france qui protège et protège nos
entreprises parce qu'elle crée de
l'emploi et qui protège nos agriculteurs
parce que ils sont la clé de notre
sécurité sanitaire de demain parce que
je suis français je veux aussi une
europe qui me donne envie d'être fiers
d'être européen une robe d'ambition et
de projets général de gaulle 10 la
france n'est grande que lorsqu'elle
parle au monde
eh bien parlons à l'europe et nous avons
déjà parlé à l'europe
nous avons déjà eu la langue française
qui est de moscou en prusse et est la
langue officielle
nous avons essais mais l'idée de liberté
que nous avons tirée de la révolution
française au travers de tous les peuples
et la marseillaise a été chantée par
tous ceux qui espéraient abattre les
tyrans cet héritage là nous en sommes
redevables
nous en sommes nous sommes les fidèles
de cet esprit français qui regardaient
l'europe non pas en conquête mais en
conviction
je veux une robe de réussite et de
progrès je veux être fiers qu'un jour on
dise c'est en europe qu'on a trouvé le
vaccin contre l'alzheimer
c'est en europe qu'on a trouvé un géant
en matière d'internet ou d'intelligence
artificielle
c'est en europe qu'on a créé des grandes
infrastructures de déplacement à la la
limite de l'invention et de l'espérance
oui
notre culture a traversé l'europe mais
nos technologies doivent être portés par
l'europe et nous devons être fiers de ce
projet européen oui je me souviens
d'airbus je me souviens d'ariane je me
souviens de ces symboles qui faisait que
on disait avec fierté je suis européen
parce que je suis français et bien je
voudrais qu'on puisse continuer à dire
je suis européen et je suis français et
parce que je suis français je suis
européen des amis je sais vous le savez
nous le sentons au plus profond de nous
il existe une civilisation européenne il
existe dans ce territoire des forêts qui
se ressemblent des paysages qui sont
semblables des rivages qui nous
réconcilie avec la vie
il existe dans ce territoire des
clochers des églises qui se ressemblent
d'un côté à l'autre de la frontière et
qu'ils disent oui il ya une identité oui
à une civilisation et vous savez d'où
elle vient
vous savez qu'elle vient du fond des
âges elle vient de cette culture grecque
qu'accepter le tragique de la vie
elle vient de cette culture chrétienne
qui à regarder l'autre non pas comme un
adversaire mais comme un frère elle
vient de cette culture des libertés et
ce n'est pas par hasard si l'humanisme
est né en europe avec pétrarque avec
erasme avec diderot avec voltaire avec
rabelais avec can't we nous avons une
pensée européenne parce que les pensées
européenne même s'il se sont fourvoyés
quelquefois dans la guerre elles sont
maintenues au du sud et peuple et elles
ont imprégné le fond des coeurs des
peuples cette civilisation européenne
c'est la mienne
et cette idée de respect de la personne
humaine
cette idée que l'homme n'est jamais un
moyen est toujours une fin cette idée
que la dignité n'est pas négociable à
cette idée que la qualité entre les
hommes et les femmes n'a pas besoin
comme le disait si bien ce matin aux
femmes de se cacher ou de se voiler et
bien c'est ça notre liberté
c'est ça notre culture et c'est ça notre
site
chers amis merci rang merci de faire en
sorte qu'on soit là trois trous et
chaque heure entre nous des différences
les différences d'âge sont les plus
visibles les différences de sensibilité
peuvent exister aussi mais nous sommes
rassemblés dans cette fierté et parce
que je suis français je peux dire avec
fierté comme le déclarait simone veil
-le l'europe c'est le grand des saints
du xxième siècle et c'est en grande
partie à nous à nous français de relever
ce défi et d'assumer cette ambition vive
l'europe vive la france
[Applaudissements]